and back in this country a panel of FDA
Health advisors is unanimously
recommending that a popular birth
control pill should be sold over the
counter now if it's approved women will
be able to buy this pill without a
prescription for the very first time
ever in the United States as Meg Oliver
reports a final decision is expected
this summer but approval is not
guaranteed
first approved in the 1970s the birth
control drug Opel has been prescribed by
doctors for decades now it could hit
store shelves by the end of the year
this really provides women with a lot
more autonomy and control over their
contraception and how and when they get
pregnant in order to be effective Opel
needs to be taken every day at the same
time within a three-hour window but some
consumers should avoid the drug
completely the Opel may not be as
effective in women who are overweight
and could cause medical issues and
complications if you are somebody who
has breast cancer or abnormal vaginal
bleeding the FDA panel weighed concerns
that some people may not follow
instructions but said the benefits of
the pill outweigh potential risks the
Catholic Medical Association is among
the groups that have raised objections
to the pill the association says it was
disappointed in the decision given the
extensive medical studies demonstrating
the risks and adverse effects the drug
maker has yet to release any information
on opel's potential pricing for CBS
mornings I'm Meg Oliver in New York
I think this is very exciting news that
more options women have I think the
better off everybody is whatever the
decisions are you're making in your life
and for men three words of us sector me
forwards vasectomy you know a little
something I know a little something
about it I endorse it